[Music]
welcome to
session 54 in the worlds of speculative
fiction series this time
we are continuing what we started in the
previous
session looking at the second volume
of the world of tears series by philip
jose farmer
and that is three novels just like the
previous one
was behind the walls of terra the
lavalite world
and the conclusion of the series more
than fire you can get them all in one
single
omnibus volume they've been bundled
together that way
in edition after addition and
each of these is a different kind of
novel in a different setting they're all
in the same
basic narrative universe i'm using the
word
universe there in a very inclusive way
as we'll see because
pocket universes are one of the
key thematics of the setting of these
and
indeed of you might say the grand plot
as well so we're going to
look at a number of different
philosophical themes that come up in
this and the world building
that philip jose farmer is engaged in
we'll also talk about
characters and plot and
how he's going to bring these to
a successful conclusion we don't need to
do an
awful lot in the way of biography
because we've already devoted two full
sessions to philip jose farmer
one very early on in the second year of
this
series and another one just a month ago
i should tell those who aren't familiar
with this series what it's all about
so this is a series that i started back
in 2016 when we moved
back here from new york to milwaukee and
i partnered with the
brookfield public library to do
in-person sessions
focusing on speculative fiction on
world building and philosophical themes
so after an initial
session which was devoted to just
talking about
you know what is the nature of
speculative fiction what does it include
differences between fantasy and science
fiction and some other
genres and and you know talking about
what the series was going to do
we jumped in looking at tolkien and
lewis
and van vote and a whole bunch of other
people
concluding the year with if i remember
right talking about george rr
martin because you know game of thrones
based on his song of ice and fire was
was a big deal
and i was invited back to continue
the series for me it was about a way in
which i could do some guilty pleasure
reading return to
narrative universes and series that i
had remembered
liking back in the day and and
reconsidering them
from a number of different perspectives
and we had a lot of great engagement and
dialogue
about what was going on we continued
year after year
after year until the covid pandemic hit
and then after a number of months of not
doing anything with the series i decided
to
resuscitate it in this current form
where i produce a video and talk about
all these things directly to an audience
and then we have a session afterwards
to discuss the matters so this time
around we are finishing
up with philip jose farmer i will tell
you that myself
i first encountered philip jose farmer
i believe in middle school and
it wasn't the world of tears series it
was instead the riverboat
and some of his short stories
collections
and some of the other novels that he'd
written and i very much enjoyed it and
then in high school
i found the world of tears at the
waukesha public library
read my way through them found them you
know quite interesting
and i enjoyed them quite a bit so i
thought it would be great to come
back to this philip jose farmer is
really known for a wide range of stuff
but i'll say that there's
three big series
that he's probably best known for one of
them is the day world series another
is the um stuff having to do
with with the river world you know
there's a whole
set of novels really excellent stuff
that i i think there
and then it's the world of tears so
we're gonna delve into this and with no
further ado
let's talk a little bit about biography
these books coming out
and some of the reception of them
by the time that the first entries
in this series the maker of universes
gates of creation a private cosmos are
being written
the ones that we find in volume one of
this collection
phillip jose farmer was a pretty well
established sci-fi author
and he's still working regular
jobs at the same time but he's moving
more and more towards becoming
and you know an author full-time
these other three novels in the series
are a bit more
spread out so the first one
which is um behind the walls of terra
is 1970 the previous ones were
1965 1966
and then 1968 so he's bringing these
books out
fairly quickly and he's writing other
things
at the same time 1970
he publishes a lot of different
books there's behind the walls of tara
lord of the trees the mad goblin lord
tiger the stone
god and the stone god awakens and he's
also
working on the things that are going to
go into the
probably more popular down the line
river world series in 1971
he's going to publish to your scattered
bodies go the fabulous riverboat and
then another book
down the black gang and
also important in 1970 the farmers moved
back
to peoria um you know important place
for for philip jose farmer peoria
illinois just
actually south of here not too far
i've had relatives who've lived there
and passed through there
many times myself and
so what we've got here with the first
book
in this second you know trio second
trilogy
behind the walls of tara is he's writing
it at a time that a lot of stuff
is going on it's in in some ways
continuing the story
of the world of tears in a way that
makes good
sense we'll talk about exactly what's
happening with setting
but terra the mention of that that's
earth right so the previous books
are set in other places other than when
wolf
leaves earth in the first few chapters
of the first one
the lavalite world is going to wait a
while before
it's coming out so that is 1977.
um now there there was a bit of writer's
block that
farmer experienced but it wasn't that
much of a writer's block since he's
publishing
quite a few things in the intermediary
time
including tarzan alive
doc savage his apocalyptic life um
venus on the half shell all sorts of
other you know interesting
works the lavalite world is going to get
published in 1977
at the same time as the dark design so
he's taking
back up the river world series and we
see him churning those out 1979
river world and other stories 1980 the
magic labyrinth river world war
the suppressed fiction of philip jose
farmer and
in the early 80s more of the river world
series when is um the
last installation more than fire
going to come out well that's going to
wait a while and
actually he he writes another book in
the
intermediary time that a little bit of
debate about whether it belongs
in this series or not it's called red
orcs rage
and it is using
the previous five books
in this world of tears series
as part of
the narrative universe but as a
narrative universe as
a fantasy uh role-playing thing
um for this other novel which is
based interestingly enough on some work
that was being done
by a therapist using philip jose farmer
stuff
we're going to put red oryx rage aside i
just want to mention though when does
that actually come out 1991
so big you know gap between 1977
and 1991 more than fire is coming out in
1993
so you know a different era a different
time
more than a decade intervening the other
thing that i'll point out too
is that these books are a little bit
longer
the the entire volume is still only
544 pages so each of these
is you know shorter than than
the other than many other books but
they're longer than the other world of
tears
books and this volume actually begins
with
um more than fire on page
329
so you know it's probably the longer one
in this bunch and there's a lot going on
in there
now interestingly enough
these books were not all that well
received
and i i do want to look at
some of the reception because i think
it's it's interestingly
setting a stage before that though i
just want to bring up one thing from the
pilgrimage to
peoria that has philip jose farmer being
interviewed
he said in the interview you mentioned
in 1990 that the tears series would
probably be two more books cake haka's
world
and the conclusion of the series the
garden of evil since then
you wrote red oryx rage and more than
fire how do these tie in with your
original plans
philip jose farmer says i intended to
then but things change you get new ideas
the titles of the first three
world of tears books were not mine they
were dreamed up by editor don
wolheim kikako's world was an idea and
title i originally suggested for a
private cosmos
and it's interesting because kikaka ends
up becoming
you know really the most important main
character
and this last book more than fire
ends with a paragraph in which kikaka
is going to tell us something i'll i'll
just read this to you
he would never again leave this world
the land area of which was larger than
earth's to roman it forever with ananah
by his side
would be to live in heaven though it
would be
unlike heaven and that it had a streak
of hell and he could be killed
ah that gave it its savor my world he
shouted
and while these words soared out over
the planet they were followed by a roar
like a lion notifying everybody
this was his territory kikaka's world
and that's that's how farmer ends this
series with his protagonist
and many people believe and farmer
himself admitted
his alter ego the person he kind of
would like to be
this trickster kikaka expressing
how this narrative universe and this
particular pocket universe
created by wolf uh ruled by
you know him uh as his friend one of the
lords
is now kikaka's world and and it's
really quite emblematic because
kikaka really does take over the series
doesn't he
right from book three onward
and and then all the way to the end he
is the one who's
who's really driving the story anyway
coming back to this
so farmers asked so is the tears series
finished
and farmer says yes i think i've mined
that vein i have too many other things
to write and not enough
time left and this is you know um
he's he's saying this after the
publication
of more than fire in 1993 he's going to
die
in peoria in 2009 so you know
fairly prescient about this he has
another
you know another uh
16 15 years left but
he had a lot of other things that he was
working on now i want to tell you about
some of these reviews
they're rather mixed and i kind of
suspect
that it's because people were looking
for
something that they saw in the original
volumes that they weren't seeing in
these newer volumes and i think it's a
really good question to open up for
those who
in fact have read these books whether
these reviews
are reflective of the objective
quality of these works or maybe
there's something else going on there so
beyond behind the walls of tara
1970 right here's one review
the result is a lively enough action
story but if you've read the earlier
books you're bound to miss
the trickster character that made the
original kikaka
so attractive he was the loki of farmers
asgard and now he seems to have
diminished into just another
vigorous hero maybe he's just resting
between
exploits isn't that an interesting
suggestion
um here's another one that's a little
bit less sanguine a novel that is
essentially one extended chase scene
with hero and heroin attempting to
outrun
and outwit a bunch of hired guns
directed by several immortals called
lords
who are somewhat inept secret masters
good writing
excellent pacing make it worth reading
as an adventure story
but an overwhelming whelming shallowness
prevents it from being anything more
than that it has the
additional curious flaw of not ending it
breaks off halfway down page 188 right
in the middle of the action
like a magazine serial right
here's another review this wasn't
exactly a disappointment
the cover leads you to expect very
little in what you receive is a short
step above this
mr farmer has written many fine pieces
in the past
but this continuation of the master
makers of universes could have used a
long passage in the polish
rewrite bin and then he says to counter
that though
some of the ideas have fascinating
possibilities
but just aren't developed or utilized to
my taste my intuition
signals that this was a rush job
another one there you have it and i hope
you're as dismayed as you should be um
one or the other had to ride and i'm
afraid that in behind the walls both
fantasy and satire suffered horribly
because kikaka and his broad one of the
lords were pretty shaggy characters
and the entire series is roughhouse
anyway farmer had to depict certain
contemporary components of our society
in a rather broad satirical
searchlight only it doesn't search it
just blinds blinds kakaka
and were we that naive the readers to
the obvious complexities of said
issues he says it's supposed to be
satire but it's so crude it rips up the
ground before it gets near the target
and that's
bad that's reactionary frankly even
though you know what a miss shot the
product is
from farmer's intent that's disgusting
right
so that's rather over the top written
you know in 1971
it reminds me very much of the music
critics who entirely
dismissed heavy metal as it was
developing and turning into one of the
you know most resilient genres ever
that these uh and the bands that were
being written about and
written off right but there is something
there is something uh that we can put on
the table
are these a rush job that's going to be
a complaint made about some of the
other novels as well is there a
shallowness to this particular
novel behind the walls of tara there's
cool ideas being put out there
are they being adequately developed and
exploited i'm going to say yes and
we'll see why in a bit but i think some
people just didn't see that at the time
lavalite world coming in seven years
later
again we see this this worry about
editing
one of the uh reviewers said it's a
fast-moving burrows type adventure which
reads like somewhat sloppy first draft
another wrote in his this final novel
lavalite world
kikaka is battling the lord urthona and
battling the landscape of the planet
which is
in constant turmoil which is kind of a
cool idea
he says interesting series of wonders
and amazes for the reader
in my stated reader mode i suspected
that phil
that is philip jose farmer was
conscientiously running through all the
dangers
inherent on the planet and moon and then
wrapped it up nicely with a happy ending
struck me as rather mechanical but what
the hell i enjoyed it but didn't believe
it for a minute
that's an interesting set of
observations
finally we get to more than fire
and there's a lot of different reviews
of this by the way all these reviews
are coming directly from the philip jose
farmer
website so you know they're they're not
candy coating what other people had to
say about it
so here's here's a 1993 review this
seems intended to be the conclusion of
farmer's world of tears series it
resembles somewhat one of his famous
river world
tales in that it is essentially a
playground for farmers exceedingly
fertile imagination
the threat of plot that runs throughout
world of tears is the contention between
the earth born
hiro kikaka and lord red orc deadliest
inhabitant of pocket universes that make
up the tears
and also champion of the arrogant and
decadent lords
in more than fire the rivalry reaches a
climax of fast action
and ingenious touches in world building
the fact that farmers notions of sexy
are what were considered taboo breaking
a generation ago
may affect the reception of this book or
not
farmers large established readership
will not be disappointed so that's
that's a rather positive
review here's here's another one
hugo award farmer hugo award winner
farmer redworks rage returns to his
popular world of tears for a
disappointing conclusion
tears is in a continuum of often very
different pocket universes
created by the super powerful lords
skipping down a little bit
um for the most part kikaka and his
lover anana
wander aimlessly from universe to
universe until they're captured by red
orc
who in the manner of foolish villains
everywhere toys with them long enough
for kikaka to escape and force a final
climactic
confrontation the world of tiered novels
were always mainly action and adventure
nothing deep but here farmer fails to
deliver even that
the action is flat the plot hopelessly
contrived
the character is less engaging than in
previous outings
and the new worlds less vivid and the
prose is often worse than even pulp
adventure
ought to be even die hard fans of the
series will likely be
disappointed so yeah that's you know
kind of a tough one
right there
another review points out that more than
fire reads as if the author had started
writing the next adventure of
kikaka right after completing the
lavalite world but it decided to add to
the mix something of his sexy violent
essex house
house work right i'm not quite sure what
a sixth house is but it gets mentioned
several times
in this review um he says
like the river world the universes of
the lords offer boundless playgrounds
for adventuring worlds of endless
variety where just about anything humans
can remotely be imagined
is liable to turn up even if it's a
little crazy violent
sexy or off-center also like the river
world
our understanding of it is subject to
endless revisions
as previous accounts are revealed to be
erroneous or deliberately
misleading it's a world conducive to
suspicion
or even paranoia where all possible
lives deceits mistakes and
misinterpretations
have to be anticipated and allowed for
and even then
there can be surprises the world of
tears is probably after the riverworld
farmer's most popular creation and
appropriately so
since i suspect it is close to his own
heart interesting one there right
i'll just read one more um
[Music]
this is kind of a funny one
the cover promises shirtless macho men
guns martial arts exotic worlds love
peril and elaborate computer at the very
least what
readers get is the very least for 250
pages
our man kikaka the trickster travels
through gates into other worlds
either running from or towards his
arch-enemy
red orc kikaka's tricky escapes are
usually achieved by some thoen lords
ringing the gates to drop them where the
lords darn while pleased to annoy
one another after cacac has been
manipulated by this lord and that he
finally battles
the red orc and the hand-to-hand comet
combat promised on the cover
the fight is what the readers expected
all along if they've lasted this long
testicle grabbing eyeball crushing blood
spouting action
but kikaka and red orc both live for
hundreds of pages and hundreds maybe
thousands of years
these enemies vowed to murder each other
and in the end they settle for a
lobotomy
for the loser more than fire is supposed
to be the climatic final chapter to
farmers world of tears series
followers of the series must ignore the
inconsistent language
and focus on the action which must have
occurred in the earlier novels there's
no fire here as well damning
criticism isn't that now what can we say
about all this
maybe some of it has to do with critics
needing to score points at the time
um are the if you only went by these
reviews you would say well
i don't know that i really want to read
these
having read them myself as you know
i guess not quite a young man just a
teenager
and then having read them again recently
several times i would say that these
critics are actually
quite mistaken about the
about several points i mean all of them
do acknowledge that there's a lot of
action going on the question is does the
action
make any sense or is it just farmer
writing essentially pickeresque novels
in which
kikaka you know engages perhaps in some
wish fulfillment
on farmer's part if we want to get all
you know freudian
critique about this or is there
is there a coherent plot going
on within these novels are there
grand themes that are being explored
do these actually have any depth to them
are they worth checking out or are they
something that we can
say well they had their day but you know
river world that's
great um day world pretty good too this
will leave behind
i would say that's that's that's a wrong
view of it now they are
fun fast-paced stories um
there are a lot of cool ideas being
brought up
the the issue of paranoia that one of
the reviewers brought up
is indeed a real concern
within these works so i'm going to hit
on that
as one of the philosophical themes
of tying it in with the question of the
lord's
so that's well worth examining and
working through i will say that i think
that
many of the reviews are you know
off and um missing
the reviewer must have missed something
in these but you'll have to decide as
you yourself read through these
let's talk now about
the worlds the pocket universes
and how people are getting from one to
the other and why they're doing that so
we're gonna
have a bit of the plot a bit of
discussion of characters
a bit of sort of review but we'll be
focusing on the world building
that is continuing in these
very interesting works these
worlds of speculative fiction series
sessions would be nothing without
talking about world building
we've already done this a bit in the
previous section
looking at the first three novels so
some of what we're going to be doing
here
you might say is a little bit of review
and then
addition right because farmer in his
universe's his narrative universe
is adding in new
pocket universes new worlds that the
lords
have created he's also doing
something kind of extraordinary in
the fourth book we'll get to that in
just a moment
before that though i do want to take on
something that that certain critics have
levied against philip jose farmer and
and they did this
in a way not just to classify but also
to in a certain way
we might say put down this this series
and indeed farmers works in general
this would also apply to the river world
series so
this is billed as science fiction
but some people say it's not really
science fiction at all
it's really science fantasy and what is
science fantasy it's kind of a hybrid
where there isn't much science involved
in it whether
hard science you know physics chemistry
all the the things that go into space
flight or any of those sorts of matters
in this case we don't need them because
we have gates right
or even the sociological
or soft or human sciences right
and i would say that
this is not entirely correct
there is a lot of technology in this
that nobody actually knows how to use
uh farmer i suppose gets around that
problem by saying the lords themselves
had scientists
but the current lords have no idea what
they're doing with these devices
in the sense of like understanding their
guts understanding them in and out
but they are actually using the very
powerful devices
and red orc perhaps does in fact
understand those things because he was a
scientist in any case
i think it is fair to say that this is
science fantasy i don't see that
as making these books
less good you know in any important
respect they're still telling
excellent stories they're still engaging
in interesting speculation
so putting that aside for the moment
although i i should mention
one really central aspect of this that
is science fantasy
rather than science fiction
is the use of the gates right not only
do we have these pocket universes but
you move from one
pocket universe to the other by means of
these
rarely present in the universes but
present all the time in the stories
uh sorts of mechanisms and there are a
number of different worlds
so what is philip jose farmer adding to
the story here
the lavalite world which is created by
orthona
is this world which is constantly in
flux
the world itself is the landscape
changes
over time you can't count on anything
it's stocked with all sorts of
horrible creatures that earthona made in
his
his bio labs like you know carnivorous
trees that
roam the wilderness by the thousands
uh you know all sorts of other
interesting animals that could kill you
and then there's human beings that he
brought from elsewhere and these human
beings exist in a kind of miserable
condition they
they don't have fire so they have to eat
all their meat raw
they routinely raid other tribes to try
to steal their children because life
although you know lifespans can be very
long
odds are they're not going to be and in
order for tribes to survive you need to
constantly induct and adopt
other human beings so the other thing
that's really kind of interesting about
this lavalite world
is that every once in a while a chunk of
it breaks off
and becomes a satellite and you know
like a moon and and starts circling it
and then eventually comes back to it and
connects up with it
this is why it's the lavalite world
lavalite is another word for a lav
a lava lamp right if you've ever seen
those things you know goop kind of
floats around in it
they're popular among hippies and
college students for their rooms
so the world itself breaks off these
chunks every so often
and when they recombine it's like a
cataclysm so
dangerous place to be there's all sorts
of other features of it that i won't go
into
there's a number of of worlds that
they're jumping around
uh from one to the next in more than
fire including one world very
interesting idea
that is essentially a giant super
computer it's been
hollowed out from the inside and
the the computer has the
memory the codes for this incredibly
devastating
weapon device that red orc is after
it's also monitored and
tended to by
this this creature this robot and so
there's some interesting action
taking place there there's other
dimensions as well that are explored
for example the world of the
good lord or good goddess uh manathu
and a number of other places as well
i think that one of the highlights of
this though is found in the fourth book
because in that book behind the walls of
tara so what are the walls of terra
they are the dimensions within which
we exist right we human beings
earth and its solar system
we think that that's you know the
universe
as it turns out earth is only one of the
pocket universes that were created by
the lords
a theme that we'll explore shortly in
much greater
detail looking at the sections of the
book but what's really interesting
about the world building is that
as opposed to all the other worlds you
know the world of tears itself
jodowan's world which they spend some
time in in
more than fire as well um
as opposed to all these other
imaginative universes some of which are
kind of you know
trap or terrible worlds like uh the lava
light world right
the changing world earth is
our earth and philip jose farmer for the
first time
is no longer engaging in fantasy about
what would it be like for somebody from
earth to go into this other world like
the world of tears
or um the lavalite world
and instead he is saying what would it
be like if somebody
who has been away from this world earth
for 30 odd years returns to it in
1970 and the answer is
well at least the portion of it that
he's focusing on
california specifically los angeles
it's not a very good world compared to
these other worlds
in this world earth you know human
beings are
are overrunning the planet they're
creating smog they're
living a life that's you know not as
good as
those in other places perhaps unless you
happen to belong to the elites
uh the food even doesn't taste that good
for the most part there's all sorts of
crazy things going on there's biker
gangs there's
you know hippie bands there's uh you
know mobsters and that is where
a lot of the action is taking place
in behind the walls of terra we we also
do get to see
um you know some some other interesting
settings coming up in that including
going to the world
that the lords themselves
uh created well the lords of themselves
originated from rather
and so there's all these different
universes one thing that we can say to
sum up
is that philip jose farmer's
narrative universe is actually
a multiverse of
interconnected pocket universes which
include
earth and include all these other places
that you can get to
via these gates and
it's kind of an open-ended
place where you could probably set
additional stories
although he did you know say with more
than fire i'm done with this
and as far as i know other than maybe
some fan fiction nobody has
added to the narrative universe of the
world of tears
so that is the setting that he is
developing for us it's
you know a pretty multi-faceted one
we're moving
from place to place to place and we're
doing so
in a way that doesn't require
extensive travel like you know travel
among the stars or anything like that
instead we have this
this process of instantaneous gaiting
one of the first philosophical themes
that we should discuss
is a cosmological one that has to do
with the nature
of the universe or in this case
universes all within a single
narrative universe so you notice we're
using the word universe
there in a rather ambiguous or polysemic
way it means more than
one thing there are pocket universes
within the vast narrative universe which
is supposed to depict
an existing universe but as we're going
to find there's
an incredible revelation that
is taking place within the first
well the first 60 70 pages
of uh beyond the walls of tara
and then it's going to get expanded over
the course of that book and also
the later books so
we start with a discussion a short
discussion
between anana and kikaka
and anana says um here we go
kikaka says you barely got started
telling me the story
of your uncle and she's talking about
you know red orc
and vala who's also died in an earlier
book they don't they don't quite
know that and she says
red orc escaped however and came back to
this universe
which was the first one he made after
leaving
the homeworld and kikaka who has grown
up
in this universe earth right
says wait a second he says what
his hand flailing out knocked over his
glass of beer he paid no attention but
stared at her what did you say
she says you did do you want me to
repeat the whole thing no no that final
the part where you said he came back to
this universe
the first one he made and
ananna says yes what's so upsetting
about that
kikaka did not stutter often but now he
could quite he could not quite get the
words out
finally he said listen i accept the idea
of the pocket universes
of the lords because i've lived in one
half my life
and i know others because i've been told
about them by a man who doesn't lie and
i've seen the lords of other universes
including you
and i know there are at least one
thousand and eight of these relatively
small manufactured universes
but i'd always thought i still think
it's impossible
my you my universe is a natural one just
as you say your home universe
it was and she says well i didn't
say that she took his hand
and squeezed it dear kikaka does it
upset you so much
you must be mistaken ana he said do you
have any idea of the vastness of this
universe
in fact it's infinite no man could make
this incredibly complex and gigantic
world
my god the nearest star is four and some
light years away
and the most distant is billions of
light years away and there must be
others billions of billions
light years beyond these and then
there's the age of this universe why
this planet alone is two
and one-half billion years old the last
i heard
that's a hell of a lot older than
fifteen thousand years when the lords
moved out of their home world to make
their pocket universes
a hell of a lot older ananna smiled and
patted his head as if
she were his grandmother and he a very
small child
there there no reason to get upset love
her i wonder why wolf didn't tell you
probably he forgot it when he lost his
memory and when he got his memory back
he didn't get all of it back
or perhaps he took it for so granted
that he never considered you didn't know
just as i took it for granted how then
can you explain the infinite
size of the world in the age of earth
and the evolution of life he said
triumphantly
there how do you explain evolution the
undeniable record of the fossils carbon
14 dating
potassium argan dating i read about
these new discoveries in a magazine on
the bus
and their evidence is scientifically
irrefutable
right and that's that's where it leaves
off for the time being now notice
what's happening in this passage that
farmer has going on between these two
lovers
one of them a thon a lord who has lived
thousands of years
the other kikaka the trickster who has
lived as he points out
half his life in the pocket universe
that is the world of tears
or jodowin's world what is going on here
it's a revelation of the fact that
our not only our world earth but also
our universe
is in some respects now here we have to
be a little careful
is it a simulacrum which is a word that
will get used later on in more than fire
is it a simulation is it a
fake no but it is
a manufactured pocket universe it is not
the creation
of god although the thons or lords would
like to
pretend that they're gods it's
not the product of simple
you know astronomic physics and all of
these other you know
interesting things coming together the
animals are not simply the product of
evolution human beings as it's going to
turn out
are not simply the product of evolution
either
but in a certain way are modeled after
are made in the image of the lords
so this is a lot to take in especially
if you're not used to that and notice
that kikaka is not getting this
just as a raw beginner you know he knows
that there are all these pocket
universes but he wants to think that
earth is in some way special
and ananda has to explain this to him a
little
bit later they take up the conversation
again
so uh here we go while they walked
kikaka questioned her about red orc and
the alleged
he's saying and that's in quotes there
creation of earth
so this is what ananda tells them there
was the universe of the lords in the
beginning and that was the only one we
knew about
then after 10 000 years of civilization
my ancestors formulated the theory of
artificial universes
once the con the mathematics of the
concept was realized it was only a
matter of time
and will until the first pocket universe
was made then
the same space would hold two worlds of
space matter but
one would be impervious to the
inhabitants of the other because each
universe was at right angles to the
other you realize the term right angles
doesn't mean anything
it's just an attempt to explain
something that can only really be
explained to one who understands the
mathematics of the concept
i myself though i designed a universe of
my own and then built it
never understood the mathematics of even
how the world making
machines operated so you know this is
the story of the lords who
they have this amazing technology most
of them
the scientists class were actually wiped
out by the black bellars
so very few of them actually understand
how to make this
the the the why the causality
but they understand you know how to make
the pocket universes
so she says the first artificial
universe was constructed about 200 years
before i was born it was made by a group
of lords they didn't call themselves
lords then by the way
among whom were my father er zen and his
brother orc
orc had already lived the equivalent of
2 000 terrestrial years he'd been a
physicist then a biologist and finally a
social scientist
the initial step was like blowing a
balloon in non-space can you conceive it
i can't either but that's the way it was
explained to me you blow a balloon in
non-space
that is you create a small space or a
small universe one into which you can
gate your machines then expand the space
next to or in the time space of the
original universe
the new world is expanded so you can
gate even larger machines into it and
these expand the universe more
and you gate more machines into the
larger space
from the beginning of this making of a
new world you have set up a world which
may have quite
different physical laws than the
original universe it's a matter of
shaping the space-time matter so that
say gravity works different than in the
the original world however the first new
universe was crude you might say it
embodied no new principles it was in
fact an exact
imitation of the original well not in
the sense that it was not a copy of the
world as it was
but as it had been in our past here's
the kicker now
the copy was this my world kikaka said
earth's she nodded and said it this
universe was the first
and it was made approximately fifteen
thousand earth years ago
the solar system deviated only in small
particulars from the solar system of the
lords
this earth deviated only slightly from
the native planet of the lords
you mean he was silent when they walked
half a block and then he said
so that explains what they meant when
you said this world was fairly recent
i know that that could not be so because
potassium argan and xenon argan dating
proved irrefutably that the world is
more than two and a half billion years
old
hominid fossils have been found that are
at least one million seven hundred and
fifty thousand years old
and then we have carbon 14 and and
then he goes out and says but you're
saying that the rocks of your world
which were four and a half billion years
old were reproduced
in our universe so they were really only
made 15
000 years ago they would seem to be four
and a half billion years old and
we find fossils that prove that
dinosaurs lived
60 million years ago and we find stone
tools and skeletons of men who lived a
million years ago but these were
duplicated
from your world that's exactly right she
says so this is we should actually pause
here for a moment
this overcomes a very interesting
problem doesn't it
all of the things that science tells us
about you know
the the age and development of our
world and and you know the many things
within it just copies
from the phones world which is an older
world
she goes he goes on and says
wait a second what about the stars the
galaxies the supernovas the quasars the
millions billions of them
billions of light years away the
millions of stars in this galaxy alone
which is one hundred thousand light
years a cl across
the red shift of light he goes on and on
and on
and he says oh she says
this universe is the first and the
largest of the artificial ones
well not the largest the second one was
just as large its diameter is three
times that of the distance from the sun
to the planet pluto
if men ever build those ships of voyage
to the nearest star
they will get past the orbit of pluto
and then to a distance twice
that of pluto from the sun and then and
then the ship will enter an area where
it will be destroyed
it will run into a what shall i call it
a force field is the only term i can
think about
and it would disappear in a blaze of
energy so will any other ship the stars
are not for men mainly because
there are no stars kikaka wanted to
protest violently he felt outraged
but he forced himself to say calmly how
do you explain that
the space matter outside the orbit of
pluto is a simulacrum
a tiny simulacrum relatively tiny uh
that is but the effects of light from
the stars the nebulas and so forth the
red shift the speed of light all that
there's a warping factor that gives all
the necessary illusions
all extra plutonian astronomy all
cosmology
was false so again this is this is a
real kick in the pants
for for kikaka and it would be for any
uh
terrestrial human would it not he's
finding out that
it's not that the whole world is a
simulacrum
but it's you might say bounded
by a simulacrum that gives us the
impression of this
incredibly consistent complicated
universe that doesn't exist at all
but the world exists it's not a
simulation
that's the natural thing for people to
bring up oh this is
this means that jose phillip jose farmer
is working with simulation theory
and we should think about what that
means when we say that that we're living
in a simulation the way that some people
want to you know allah the matrix or the
13th floor
or any of these other you know movies of
that sort
what we're saying is that there's a
basis which is the real basis and then
there's the illusion
that we have and the illusion is of
what we're experiencing here and that
illusion is generated
on this basis it could be computers
could be
you know rene descartes and an evil
demon could be whatever you want right
it could be
any sort of thing but what we're seeing
is not real
that's not the case in these pocket
universes the pocket universes
are real they just happen to be
manufactured or created or
in the case of earth the imitation the
perfect imitation
of a past
now there's more to the story there's
actually two more twists that we
we have to go so
kakaka says why did the lords feel it
necessary to set up this simulacrum of
an infinite ever expanding universe with
its trillions of heavenly bodies
why didn't they just leave the sky blank
except for the moon and the planets why
this utterly cruel deception
or need i ask i had forgotten them at
the moment that the lords are cruel
she patted his hand looking up into his
eyes and said the lords are not the only
cruel ones
you forget that i told you this universe
was an exact copy of
ours i mean exact from the center that
is the sun
to the outer walls of this universe your
world is a duplicate of ours
that includes the simulacrum of
extrasolar space
he stopped and said you mean the native
world of the lords was an artificial
universe too
yes after three ships had been sent out
past our outermost planet to the nearest
star
only 4.3 light years away as we thought
a fourth ship was sent
but this had disappeared in a burst of
light it was not destroyed but could
progress no further than the first three
it was repelled by a force field or was
turned away by the structure
of the space matter continuum at that
point at
after some study we reluctantly came to
the realization there were no stars or
outer space not as we had thought of
them
the revelation was not accepted by many
people in in fact the impact of this
discovery was so great that our
civilization was in a near psychotic
state for some time
some historians have maintained it was
the discovery that we were in an
artificial comparatively finite universe
that spurred us
stung us into searching for the means of
making our own
synthetic universes because if we were
ourselves the product of a people who
made our universe
and therefore made us then we too could
make
our worlds so
cachaca says then earth's world is not
even second hand it's third hand
but who could have made your world who
are the lords
of the lords so this is another big
revelation
about the culture of these phones these
not not quite aliens but actually in
some respect
much closer to us than any alien could
be
very imaginative work here so who
are these lords of the lords who are
these
others
so there is a number of discussions
about this and one of these does take
place
in uh behind the walls of of terra
right
there's this discussion of the the world
of the lords
the one that was itself a creation but
then later on
there is um some discussion
of a creature who's found
here we go so they through gating in
they find themselves in this room
with a perhaps corpse or perhaps one in
suspended animation
and it's a sort of lizard-like man
and ana says my people had stories about
a sapient but non-human species
who preceded us though on they were said
to have created us
whether the tales were originally part
of the prehistoric thoe and cultures
or were early fiction we don't really
know but most though on
insist that we originated naturally we
were not made by anybody my ancestors
did make
your kind these are the multitude of
life forms were made in my ancestors
biofactories to populate their
artificial pocket universes
but that we throw on could be artificial
beings never
however the stories did describe the
thaukina as somewhat like that creature
there but the thulchina were a different
species from us
we were supposed to have invaded their
universe and killed all but one i don't
know they're conflicting legends about
them
one of the early tales was that the
there was the one thokina who survived
the the war and hid somewhere
he placed himself in an impenetrable
tomb then he went into a deep sleep
from which he will not be awakened until
the worlds are in danger of
destruction and so
that's one bit of the story
a little bit later on we get
an expansion of it uh
there we go
so this is when um we've been introduced
to
a lord who's not a bad guy is actually
quite a good woman who rules over her
own
pocket dimension mathonu vorkyon
and she tells him um
a a bit of the the back story as well
um she finds out that that you know
he has seen the phokina and she says it
can't be and kikaka says
why not she swung around to face him
because they're only creatures of
folklore and legend born of primitive
fears and imagination when i was a child
my parents in the house slaves told me
stories about them in some of these the
thaukina were a non-human
species who were the predecessors of the
thon the lords in other tales they made
the first thou on and enslaved them
then the thorn revolted and killed all
but one that sole survivor fled to some
unknown universe
according to the story and put himself
into a sort of suspended animation
but the tale which was a very spooky one
for a child told how he would rise one
day when the time was ripe and would
join the greatest enemy of the thorn
and help him slay all of them that
greatest enemy would be a
lobby that is a human being possibly
kikaka
all right and um
she goes on he says the tale also
described how he would then kill the
last thulin and become the lord of all
the worlds
another story said that he would join
the lababi
and help them overthrow the lords the
tales made
enjoyable hair raising stories for the
children but the tokina
could actually be that he says i'm not
lying and i was wondering about the
image of the scaly man i saw in a goblet
during
the feast and so that is
more of the back story and then we get a
little bit more
a bit later it's never fully sketched
out right
here the thokina kuruz
has been resuscitated
and is talking with kikaka
cruz had told kikaka that parts of the
outline of the legends about the kringes
the their own word for the thokina were
close to the truth but the details were
usually
wrong when the thohan people had killed
off all the cringes except for him he'd
made an underground retreat after being
there for a while
he'd stop the molecular motion of his
body and settle down for a long sleep
and what he's doing is
he's saying i'm going to sleep until
this machine wakes me up by then
the probabilities that the situation
would be considerably changed were high
the lords might have died out
their numbers were comparatively few at
the time i went into stasis
and their descendants if these existed
might be different in culture and
temperament they might be more tolerant
and empathetic or some other sentient
species higher on an ethical level than
the lords
might have replaced the thon in any
event whoever inhabited the universes
might be willing to accept me
if not then i would have to deal with
the evil as best as i could
backing up a little bit he he also tells
that
his people had been called the cringes
and uh that you know they
they were indeed the the creators so
what we've got here is a really
interesting
rich deep backstory that's being
revealed sort of like the peeling of
an onion where human beings
created by the lords manipulated by the
lords their very earth is
a creation a pocket universe but the
lords themselves the thons are not the
masters of reality
they themselves are products this can be
you know very devastating
psychologically
it can also be liberating in certain
ways as well to learn that
we're not you know
these originary beings but that were
also manufactured
doesn't necessarily have to be such a
kick in the pants we could think about
the
creation stories and i'll just mention
too
in very quick passing i will also point
out
that one of the things that hari
frankfurt the philosopher
who's you know said so much about so
many different topics points out about
the genesis
book of you know genesis account that's
so normative for
for jews and christians is that
human beings are indeed the very first
artifacts
as opposed to everything else which is
spoken into creation
god in that story takes
something clay and breathes
spirit into it and then creates
um human beings as an artifact
so we are the the tool if you like or
the
creation that is not direct
um also mentioned in the babylonian
enumeration
which in some respects bears closer
similarity to what the lords are like
here
human beings are created to be the
slaves for the gods so that the gods
don't have to be slaves for each other
and they're created out of dirt and the
blood of
a captured conquered and subjugated
god so that they can indeed
serve the the deities
so that's probably enough about that
theme
another key philosophical theme that we
ought to discuss
is this character kikaka the trickster
right
the person who has left our universe as
a fairly
young man spent a lot of time in the
world of tears made it his own
the lover of ananda the bright
all sorts of other important things and
perhaps
the the subject of a prophecy
about the lobby the human being who will
destroy the realm the the rule of the
lords now that prophecy gets
mentioned doesn't play a big role but
kikaka's ancestry is
sort of an object of speculation so
this is when um kikaka is is talking
with red orc and red orc says
you make yourself sound very tricky and
resourceful so tricky i could almost
think you were a lord
not just a lublabi earthling and then
kikaka says ana has the crazy idea it
could be the son of a lord in fact she
thinks i could be
your son orc said what and then he began
laughing and he said that felt good i
haven't laughed like that for how long
never mind so you really think you could
be my child not me cacaca said
anana she likes to speculate it because
she needs some justification
for falling in love with a lab lobby if
i could be half lord then i'd be
more acceptable but this idea is 100
wishful thinking of course
red orc says i have no children because
i want to interfere as little as
possible
with the natural development here but
you could be the child of another lord
i suppose however you've got me off the
subject and then
then it goes on again and this this gets
taken up
a little bit later in the same
book um
[Music]
here we go so red orc is talking
and he's introduced himself to kikaka
and he says the trap may be so subtle
that i was led into thinking i said it
and then perhaps i did what does it
matter we're all led here for one reason
or another to the final
battleground it has been a good battle
because we're not fighting through our
underlings
the lib lobby we're fighting directly as
we should you are the only earthling in
this battle and i'm convinced that you
may be
half lord so red orc now has come around
to
this idea and he says um
you know you you have some family
resemblances to us
i could be your father or a thona or
uriel
or even that dark one jodowin uh and
it's possible that anana could be your
mother too in which case you might be
all lord that would explain your amazing
abilities
and your successes kikaka says i don't
know what you're getting at orc but ana
couldn't possibly be my mother anyway i
know who my parents are
they were indiana farmers who came from
old american stock including the oldest
and from scotch norwegian german and
irish immigrants
i was born in the very small rural
village of north terre haute and there
is no mystery
he stopped because there had been a
mystery
his parents had moved from kentucky to
indiana and suddenly he remembered the
mysterious
uncle robert who had visited their farm
from time to time when he was very young
and there was the trouble with his birth
certificate when he had volunteered for
the army cavalry
and when he had returned from to indiana
after the war he'd been left ten
thousand dollars from an unknown
benefactor it was to put him through
college
and then there had been the vague
promise of more to come
there's no mystery red orcs said i know
far more about you than you would dream
possible
when i found out that your natal name
was paul giannis finnegan i remembered
something and i checked it out
now that and then things start kicking
off again and that's that
we do get a longer discussion
of kikaka's background and ancestry
coming up in here we go
the very end of of that
i don't book actually in the lavalite
world
and it it this is very interesting it
comes up in relation to a discussion
about a kind of loneliness and wanting
to belong
on the part of kikaka after he's been
adopted
by this this particular tribe
so he says much of his life he'd been a
loner
he was neither a social nor anti-social
he had no trouble mixing with his
playmates
because of his intense curiosity
athletic abilities and linguistic
ability he'd been both popular and a
reader
a leader but he was a voracious reader
and quite often when he had a choice
between recreation with others or
reading he decided on the latter
his time was limited because a farmer's
son was kept very busy
he also studied hard to get good grades
in school he knew he didn't want to be a
farmer he wanted to go to
far away places but that required a phd
and to get that he'd have to get high
grades through high school and college
so he read everything he could get his
hands on
and then a little bit later
an outsider observing him from the age
of 17 through 22 would not have known he
was often with his peers but not
of them they would have seen a star
athlete and superior student who palled
around with the roughest raced around
the country eight roads on a motorcycle
tumbled many girls in the hay literally
got dis disgustingly drunk
and once was jailed for running a police
roadblock his parents had been mortified
his mother weeping his father raging and
so it goes on and on and on
and he gets in trouble he gets put on
probation by the judge
and he stays on the farm and then here
here's another
key point and then mr and mrs finnegan
perhaps in an effort to straighten him
out even more perhaps in an unconscious
desire to hurt him
as he'd hurt them revealed something
that shocked him he was an adopted
child paul was stunned like most
children he'd gone through a phase when
he believed he was adopted
but he had not kept to the fantasy which
children conceived during periods when
they think their parents don't love them
but it was true and he didn't want to
believe it
according to his step parents his real
mother was an english woman with the
quaint name of philly
jane fogg fog under other circumstances
he would have thought this hilarious not
now and i'm going to skip over the long
genealogical thing going on here
so in any case the revelation had shaken
paul
terribly it was after this that he began
to suffer from a sense of loneliness or
perhaps a sense of being abandoned
once he learned all the details he
wanted to know about his true parents he
never spoke of them again
when he mentioned his parents to others
he spoke only of the man and woman who'd
reared him
two years after cacaca learned about his
true parents mr finnegan fell ill with
cancer and died in six months
this was grief enough but three months
after the burial his mother had also
fallen victim to the same disease
so kikaka stays there and you know works
on the farm
uh takes a a day a part-time job as a
mechanic
pals around with some of his friends
five years went by swiftly suddenly he
was 23.
the farm still wasn't paid off he
couldn't see himself as a farmer for the
rest of his life
so he sold the farm at a very small
profit now it was evident that his hopes
of entering college and becoming an
anthropologist
would have to we have to be set aside
the united states would be getting into
the war in a year or two
so he enlists in the cavalry winds up in
a tank
winds up over in in europe under patton
and on a brief leave you know during a
lull in the fighting
finds himself in a small museum in a
german town that he helped clear out
he found a curious object a crescent of
some silvery metal
he discharged from the army he returned
to terre haute where he didn't plan to
stay long
and he gets a check for ten thousand
dollars
from his uh his father and he says my
father he didn't have a pot to pee and
you know that not the man who adopted
you it's from your real father
where is he i'll kill him you wouldn't
want to go where he is he's six feet
under buried in a church cemetery in
oregon
he got religion years ago and became a
fire eating brimstone
drinking hallelujah shouting revival
this but the old bastard must have had
some conscious left he willed all his
estate to you
so paul goes off paul caca
to the university of indiana
and begins studies
and then the adventure begins there's a
story in the newspaper
about this silvery crescent that he
found and this man vannux comes to try
to buy it from him
and long story short we find this out in
the earlier
story he winds up paul winds up being
transported to the world of tears
yadawyn's world
and lives there for for a long time and
then there's more backstory about the
bellers and all of that because it's
it's revelation for the lavalite world
this novel that this fifth novel that's
being written later
now what do we want to focus on there so
there's a couple different themes
kicking around one is
this notion that kikaka himself
is an extraordinary individual mentally
physically
morally and so perhaps he's one of the
lord's
children and a demi lord so to speak or
perhaps he's just the best of what
humanity has to offer farmer likes to
work with
what we nowadays would call superheroes
or
you know extraordinary individuals you
see this running throughout
all of his his works
and so that's one thing but this theme
of adoption
is particularly interesting and
important and the theme of loneliness
and forging relationships he doesn't
let a lot of people in easily when he
does
it's it's a major bond his relationship
with yaduin or wolf
and chris ace wolf's consort is one his
relationship with
anana is another one very interesting
because he's offered the chance to
mate with you know to engage in
congress with effectively a goddess who
has her own
entire pocket universe and looks like
one of the lords
who's not a baddie and says no i'm
faithful to
ananda and so you know there's there's
all of this going on he
forms and forges a relationship with her
he's adopted by many different
peoples and within the scope of that
finds himself feeling a sense of
responsibility for each of them and i
think this is an important part
of this character who really is along
with ananda
the main character of these last three
novels of the world of tears
the relationship between the narrative
that philip jose farmer
is spinning out for us here in these
three interesting wrap up actually like
build out novels that comprise
volume 2 of the world of tears and other
narratives whether they be science
fiction and fantasy or pulp stuff or
whether they be the writings of blake
turn out to be an important interesting
theme
here in this work i will mention that
not only
in these books but also in some of the
earlier books
there is an interesting discussion an
interesting reference let's say
where you know kikaka will say something
like this isn't a science fiction
story you know things don't happen that
way right
and of course this is a science fiction
story so it's
it's an interesting way of uh breaking
the fourth wall so to speak
and you know trying to introduce verse
similitude
but there's a longer passage where this
guy clifton
in more than fire who's glimpsed first
in the lava light world right in in
the palace uh that's that's wandering
away from them
this guy clifton is brought up and he's
dressed kind of weird he talks kind of
weird
and it turns out that he's met blake
right william blake so
um here we go kikaka
says does this have anything to do this
this story that you're telling with the
mate with the main story
and then clifton says very much so i
cannot leave it out do you know blake's
poetry
uh cacao says i read some of his poems
when i was in high school
blake had been born if he remembered
correctly in fifth night in 1757 and had
died in 1827
he was an eccentric who is christian but
his ideas about religion differed much
from the views of his time or from any
other views
than in cacacas time this much he had
learned from his english teacher clifton
said
did you know that blake wrote blake
wrote poetic works in which he made up
his own mythology
no he mixed them with christian elements
so
his didactic and symbolical works were
apocalyptic poems in which the
characters were gods and goddesses he
invented
or said he invented he conceived his own
mythology and the deities in them had
names such as
los angeles
red orc vala and ahania
what you you must be so you're not
kidding said
he turned to ana did you know this her
eyes widened yes i did but don't get
angry with me the subject just didn't
come up though i've met blake
you've met blake kikaka was so fat
flabbergasted that he spluttered
yet he knew she must be telling the
truth this blake matter had meant little
to her and she would have recalled it
if you'd mentioned the poet's name so he
asked clifton
what happened here's what clifton says
mr blake was a mystic visionary and
exceedingly eccentric his eyes were the
wildest the brightest and the
piercingest i've ever seen
his face was like an elf one of the
dangerous elves and
as it goes on right there's more and
more discussion here about this
ring that takes place and then finally
ananna says um they're talking about
these visitations the figures of beings
and things from the
supernaturals though sometimes you spoke
of them as visitors from other
worlds anana said sometimes he called
them emanations from the unknown worlds
and cacaca said from whom did you hear
this
i heard it directly from blake as you
know after red orc made the universe of
earth and the universe
of earth's twin he forbade any lords to
visit them but some did go there and i
was one of them
i've told you that i've been on earth
one several times and though i didn't
mention all the times and places i've
been there
when i was living in london a
fascinating though disgusting place i
was disguised as a wealthy
french noble woman since i collected
some of the best of the primitive art of
earth men i went to see blake i
purchased some engravings and
temperous sketches from him but asked
him not to tell anyone i'd done so
there didn't seem the slightest chance
that red orc would hear about it but i
wasn't taking any
risks so it goes on a little bit further
and ananna says we someone who know
about blake have wondered about that
about the thon worlds our theory is that
blake was a mystic who somehow tuned in
you might say
to a knowledge of the people inhabiting
the other universes
he had a sensitivity perhaps neural
perhaps from a seventh sense we know
nothing about
no other earth person has ever had it at
least we haven't heard of his like
although there is a theory that some
earth mystics and perhaps some insane
earth people
we just don't know but somehow blake
received something
what should i call them visions
intimations of the artificial pocket
universes
perhaps of the original thon universe or
of that universe that some say preceded
the philons
in any event it couldn't have been
coincidence that he knew the exact names
of many lords
and some of the situations and events in
which they played their
parts but his uh psychic receptions of
thems were destroyed
and fragmentary and he used them as part
of his personal mythology and mangled
christian mythology
with them the mixture was and highly
imaginative
and shaped by his own beliefs blake was
a freak though of a
high order and this is very interesting
as a technique because what it allows
farmer to do
is to explain how what he's doing has
all these characters who are
semi-blake ian but that he's doing his
own thing with it
the narrative that farmer is having ana
give
is the real narrative and blake the
mystic visionary artist poet from the
past
turns out to have distorted forms of
that very clever to do that
isn't it so that's a you know a
philosophical theme that we should
mention
but i don't think we have to say much
more about that
there are a lot of other cool
philosophical themes that we could touch
on and explore much more but i'm going
to have to put them
to the side in order to concentrate on
one last theme that we brought up in the
previous session but i want to
see through a bit more before that in
passing let's just mention there's
a world that is itself a computer that's
a very interesting
idea you know administered by this robot
who
more or less can be overcome by you know
the typical tricks of of uh
figuring out what the robot in his
programming can't
understand there's also red orc as the
consummate villain
and we'll talk about him just a little
bit because we're going to talk about
the lords but it is worth mentioning
that
red orc himself seems to have been
deluded about his own
production of earth and confused himself
with another earlier orc
there's also the cool you know twist
early on in
in behind the walls of terra that
redwork
isn't actually lord of the earth at this
time it's it's orthona who's taken his
place the satire of earth 1970
well worth reading all of which is
happening in behind the walls of
terra i will just mention that the lords
in general
want their planets kept relatively clean
and earth is seen as a dirty dirty place
because red orc being the social
scientist doesn't impose that
on his experimental subjects the human
beings
what i want to talk about to bring this
to a close is the differences in the
mentalities
of the lords in relation to each other
and in relation to the
lobby or human beings lobby is sort of a
slur word
for human beings and what we see
are i've mentioned already kikaka may be
half lord may may not be um he's
certainly a humane
person we have mention of jodowin
or wolf who plays almost no role at all
except as somebody mentioned in this but
jodowin spent time
on earth among human beings was also
raised by a human couple
also adopted right and so he has
developed a perspective that is
different from those of the lords we saw
that in the second book
where he's you know castigating his
fellow lords there there is one brother
that he has who's a decent person
as well and then we also have um
this this uh goddess uh
who has her own universe and has decided
to run it for the benefit
of the lobby as sort of a benevolent
despot you know she makes everything
set up in such a ways to minimize
conflict
everybody has enough to eat it's kind of
a halcyon
place to live in um and then we have ana
and there's some very interesting back
and forth discussions in here
about how long can this couple actually
go on there's a certain point in
um behind the walls of terra or the
lavalite world
or perhaps it's at the very beginning
when they've been wandering together for
15 years and more than fire
where she says you know god's earth you
know lords
couples have been able to stay together
for maybe 50 years
tops you know i love you but maybe maybe
it's good if we do have some distance
every once in a while
and it's really quite interesting to see
the dynamics between them
and to see the development that happens
there's that mention as i i brought up
before that kikaka says
you know i think she thinks i'm half
lord because that makes it easier for
her to sleep with me and to be in love
with me because it's kind of shameful
for her and we see the disgust on the
part
of the other lords for this taking a
a human being to be not just
an occasional lover but to be your
lifelong mate somebody you care about
this comes to a peak
in the lavalite world with um
erthona and there's there's two
sections that i think are particularly
interesting and revelat
revelatory of this right
so um she's she's talking
with arthona and um
he tells her that you know what you're
doing is
is disgusting um
here we go there's a conversation
anonymous shook her head uncle i was
once like you that is utterly unworthy
of life but there was something in me
that gave me misgivings
let us call it a residue of compassion
of empathy deep under the coldness and
cruelty and arrogance was a spark
and that spark fanned into a great fire
fanned by a lablabee
called kikaka he's not a lord for he is
a man
that's more than you ever were or will
ever
be and these brutish miserable creatures
who've captured you and don't know they
hold the lord of their crazy world
captive
they're more human than you could
conceive that is their [ __ ] lords
she's had a total not just change of
heart
but change of perspective arthona stared
and said what in the spinner's name are
you talking about
anana felt like hitting him but she said
you wouldn't
ever understand perhaps i shouldn't say
ever after all i came to understand but
that was because i was forced
to be among the leblabby for a long time
and this lablabi kikaka the descendant
of an artificial product corrupted your
mind it's too bad the council is no
longer in effect
you'd be condemned and killed within 10
minutes
and then she says anana says don't
forget uncle that you
too may be the descendant of an
artificial product of creatures created
in a laboratory
don't forget that what shambara men
speculated with much
evidence to back his statement that we
too the lords
may have been made in the laboratory of
beings who are as high above us
as we are above the lublabi or should i
say as high above them as we are
supposed to be
after all we made the lobby in our image
which means that they are neither above
nor below us they are
us but they don't know that and they
have to live in worlds that we
created made rather we are not creators
any more than writers of fiction or
painters are creators
they make worlds but they are never able
to make more than what they know
they can write or paint worlds based on
the elements of the known
put together in a different order in
such a way as to make them seem to be
creators
we the so-called lords did no more than
poets writers and painters and sculptors
we are not we are we were not and we are
not gods
though we've come to think of ourselves
as such spare me your lectures or thona
says i don't care for your attempts
to justify your degeneracy so we have a
very important conflict here
this does also touch on the earlier
mentioned themes of the creations of
universes
and the references to other
literary forms now a little bit later
where um anana probably should have
killed persona
but didn't do so there is
a interesting conflict
so orthona says you won't come with us
now
and she says i get no here we go
at least you won't tell the chief what
we're planning to do i get no special
pleasure out of that she said the only
thing is how do i explain your french
leave
how do i you know explain all these
sorts of things
a little bit earlier than that you know
he says why
uh you know we should get away now and
she says why would i want to go with you
you surely don't want to spend the rest
of your life here and she says i don't
intend to but i
mean to make sure first that kikaka is
either alive or dead
that lib lobby means that much to you
yes don't look so disgusted if you
should ever feel that much for another
human being which i doubt
you'll know why i'm making sure about
that and then earthona
gets gets very angry with her and
actually goes to attack her
disgusted by the fact that she
loves kikaka so a lot of different
things at play here
what else can we say about the lords we
know that as children many of them were
all right but then they were corrupted
and what what corrupted them there's a
lot of mentions
of the paranoia of the lords
why are they paranoid and this is
something that comes up in book after
book after book their paranoia
is so blinding that they can't tell the
difference between
reality and imagination
or you know falsehood
why are they so paranoid well in part
because they have
all of this power but they also lack
knowledge about the powers that they're
working with
and they're antagonistic towards each
other there's a almost
hobbesian dilemma that goes on where if
you can't trust that lord over there
and you know that they can't trust you
you have to strike first
so that you can wipe them out this is
what thomas hobbes called
anticipation or diffidence as opposed to
mere
competition what can get them out of
that
the only things that can are being
thrown in together and having to work
together
against another lord or against the
environment that they're in
and then everything breaks down once
again
or forming attachments and this is where
the familial stuff
can play a role as it did in earlier
books or
love can play a role or some sort of
ideals that's the only thing that can
really
transport lords out of their
as she calls as anana
calls it and kikaka calls it at a
certain point
not just egoistic but almost solipsistic
way of being so that that's a good theme
to end upon we finished the series
with kikaka and ananna being you know
brought back together after all these
trials and travails after so much death
destruction and in effect saving the
universe
from red orc as well as from other
forces and winding up again
in the world of tears kikaka's world
[Music]
you